welcome to the broken podcast my name is
Pierre PAH
with me is cinnamon to ski hello hello
anyway we love our friends so we're
gonna interact with you today
so we're gonna draw together the goal is
to not draw anything offensive good look
all right all right all right it's not
offensive binetex
it's been like ten seconds I swear to
God get down
take it down we need more color Hey no
no not colors epilepsy warning offense
Jim Jesus we're supposed to wait wait
this is not gonna work Jesus Christ
thanks oh there it is Dick's everywhere
fine chat that's great that's just great
I got there's one guy trying really hard
to draw dicks while the others just what
are we doing here yeah we can't even
draw dicks
okay you know what maybe you should
tweet instead thanks guys thanks for
living up to that good rep
okay I'm going okay I got a sweet ass
[ __ ] cat going here look at him go
he's so happy
okay he's so happy look at is not happy
your cat looks like a poop hole in the
face
you're a poop hole in the face my cat
literally literally literally literally
shits all over your cat ha ha ha Thank
You kitty oh no what are you doing
that's not a cat my cat's did draw cats
jay-z
get the [ __ ] out but what does this cat
over here is stupid you can't I don't
believe my dad I'll delete your cat
no give you a better kit chief he's
protective to look at this Apple I love
you Chen don't [ __ ] you know loves you
can they all love me can the dead again
you did it good job all right next round
it's been a I'm then post Thanks so
let's draw Simpa uh what must Impa my
senpai does not look that hot to be
honest hey hey what the [ __ ] you can't
just come in here this is not sent by
yours look like a state or something
what is that Texas be talking about the
dinosaur Oh Simba what is this I'm
deleting everything that looks like [ __ ]
all that's a Alice's got something cool
going on I don't know what else is doing
yeah yeah Maryanne avails noticed me
why would you draw a banana why is there
a banana and Eris oh well we have one
good drawing I think that I think that's
the best one so far yeah I like it this
is nice
uh draw Ken muscle here lexan there we
go
oops okay we got it
why do they always start with these
[ __ ] weird as lying is this Gary like
you can do I need two pairs of legit
drawings here definitions why are you
better at drawing than me when since
when did this happen
looks like a what is this is like my
gravestone up here is dead beer but the
part never dead like this one it looks
so kawaii I don't really go I can you
they're pretty cool eggs
damn your friends are way better yeah
look at him it's not fair everyone final
round draw pity pie
[ __ ] you and your [ __ ] line every
[ __ ] time sorry I got a little okay
you know what no not allowing this why
why is there any time there's PewDiePie
oh there's a Doug you know what [ __ ] you
stop you suck and what is this you like
second something over here Oh what is
this [ __ ] water cover no my turn
Oh trash altered here [ __ ] oh yeah he
smells Jesus Christ every way we draw
you everyone's so like in their own
little space it was I read a dotted geek
or whatever in the name alright I'm just
gonna draw myself well my guy is still
in the corner look at this huge penis
come on this penis here no just kidding
it's glass oh my balls are almost bigger
than my penis oh yeah now it's tits got
a brief that bullet-proof you'll be
wearing
yeah someone's someone's colored my hair
for me thanks skunky so draw dick with
the headphones thank you so much penis
ear
now we're getting someone there we go
wow you're peeing on the potato I don't
know why I would do that being on myself
technically cuz this is all me yeah
that's true I got like this wow I think
you're eating a piece of toast right
here oh how do I taste like cinnamon Oh
mescaline and like babe oh babe oh oh oh
let me know what's going on here anymore
ah there you go
we did it fantastic and you did it um
okay that I was that great good let's
move on with the [ __ ] show